هذا وشكلت المعارك التي دارت حول مصنع
ازوكستان في مدينه ماريوكول علامه فارقه
في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا فموقع المصنع
واهميته الاستراتيجيه جعله في مقدمه
الاهداف التي سعت روسيا للسيطره عليها
فريق الجزيره تجول في مصنع
وكان اول وسيله اعلام اجنبيه تدخل المصنع
بعد سيطره الجيش الروسي عليه في ايار
هنا ازوستال في ماريو بول حيث الدمار ولا
شيء غيره
دخلنا المصنع للاطلاع على حاله بعد ما
شهده من معارك بين الجيشين الروسي
والاوكراني استمرت لاكثر من شهرين
السلطات الروسيه تقول اليوم انها لن تعيد
ترميم المصنع وتستعد لتفكيكه بعد ازاله
الالغام وبقايا المتفجرات من نحو 80% من
مساحته كما يؤكد لنا مدير شركه مساهمه في
المشروع رفض اظهار ملامحه لاسباب قال انها
امنيه
هذا المصنع الذي شيد عام
1933 معقده لذلك لن يعاد ترميمه ستفككه
هذه الورش بمشاركه ثلاث شركات الروسيه وهي
عمليه ستستغرق عاما الى عامين حسب الظروف
استمدستال ومن خلفه مدينه ماريوتو الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه في الحرب من موقعهما
الجغرافي المطل على بحر ازوف ساعات روسيا
منذ اول يوم الى عزل الساحل الجنوبي عن
اوكرانيا بهدف تامين ممر بري عبر طريق
حيوي يربط مقاطعه روستوف بشبه جزيره القرم
طريق وصلت فيه الاشغال اليوم مراحل متقدمه
العالم كاحدى اعنى في حلقات الحرب في
اوكرانيا
وبسيطره روسيا على المصنع كاخر جيب مقاومه
في المنطقه ككل خسرت اوكرانيا كل منافذها
البحريه بما في ذلك ثلاثا من اهم مدنها
وابرزها ماريو بولا المرشحه لان تصبح نقطه
ارتكاز بحري وبري للقوات الروسيه في
المنطقه حسابات الاستراتيجيه تفسر على ما
يبدو اسباب التمسك اوكرانيا بالمدينه حتى
اخر غمق واسرار روسيا على انتاعها بكل ما
اوتيت من قوه حاولت المعارك مصنع ازوستال
الى كومه من الركام قد تستغرق عمليه
ازالته عده سنوات كما جعلت منه رمزا يصعب
نحوه من ذاكرته هذه الحرب وان اختلفت نظره
كل طرف الى ما يمثله
بين النصر والالم والصمود